we talked last week about fox news
starting to set up
support of ron desantis for president in
2024 support for ron desantis is the
republican nominee in 2024 and an
abandonment of bailing out a uh an
escape from support for former president
donald trump and we played some clips in
fact from fox news that indicated that
they're not saying
we would we would support a democrat
over trump but fox news seems to be very
clearly positioning itself to support
someone other than trump in the primary
donald trump has now completely flipped
out on fox and friends
because fox and friends simply
acknowledged there are polls that show
ron desantis ahead of donald trump for
the 2024 republican primary they didn't
even say we prefer desantis they didn't
say trump sucks they didn't say sir we
don't want you anymore they just said
there are polls in which desantis is
leading and trump
raging on troth central at fox and
friends so let's look first at the clip
and this is so milk toast this is so
banal it's just
there are polls that say desantis is
doing better you've got people from all
across the country convening in tampa
i am thinking about um
that is a little different than a couple
of other polls that we've seen over the
last couple of weeks two weeks ago in
florida blue point uh rather blueprint
polling did a poll
desantis leads the former president in
all age groupings
then there was a university of new
hampshire poll in june
desantis actually led trump 39-37
and that new york times sienna a college
poll that we decided quite a few times
less than half of republican voters back
donald trump as their preferred choice
so it's like the young people who are
activists at that event right
like the former president but looking at
these other polls
a different answer yeah if you look
state by state ron desantis is showing
tremendous strength in new hampshire
michigan and florida tremendous strength
he's leading or tied with the former
president uh and turning point run by
charlie kirk extremely impressive
organization and they are extremely
enthusiastic and active us
yeah so
pretty milk toast guys it's like trump's
doing well in some places but desantis
as well in others and there's some polls
in which desantis is either tied or
leading that's just what it is these are
just facts and donald trump triggered on
his platform truth social truth
essential by any suggestion that maybe
someone in the republican party might
vote for somebody else trump posting
almost immediately
fox and friends just really botched my
poll numbers no doubt on purpose why
would they botch it on purpose well i
guess if you think that they're starting
to build a campaign against you you
would think that that show has been
terrible gone to the dark side they
quickly quote the big turning point poll
victory of almost 60 points over the
number two republican and then hammer me
with liars actually almost all polls
have me leading all republicans and
biden by a lot
rhino paul ryan one of the weakest and
worst speakers ever
must be running the place anyway
thank you to turning point the crowd and
love was amazing this is exactly what
we've been hoping for
fracture the party
let them tear themselves apart destroy
the party and an important reminder on
this fox news thing
just because fox is setting itself up to
probably turn on trump and support
desantis in the republican primary that
doesn't actually mean fox news number
one has the power to turn the republican
party against donald trump and it also
doesn't mean that if trump is the
nominee in 24 that fox won't get in line
and support him over whoever is the
democratic nominee obviously they will
let's take those two things one at a
time
in 2016 donald trump won the republican
primary with fox against him from the
get-go it was a long primary in 2016 for
the republican party it started in 2015
in fact and there were
18 16 candidates some large number of
candidates donald trump started polling
almost nothing early fox news did not
support trump for the absolute longest
time eventually when donald trump had
gained a bunch of momentum
by attrition as the one two three
percent candidates dropped out
and trump was able to start coalescing
support and the evangelicals eventually
reluctantly came over to trump after he
told some story about how he's against
abortion now
fox news eventually acquiesced but they
were against trump and trump still won
so first of all it's not clear fox
really has the power to torpedo the
trump pres trump uh candidacy in the
republican primary secondly um trump is
going to continue doing his rallies
um finding ways to reach most of his
base even without fox news necessarily
on his side even without being on
twitter so that's not going to be a
problem and maybe the most important
thing is in the end fox news is going to
get in line and fox news will get in
line for two reasons one fox can't
support a democrat that would completely
torpedo their brand that wouldn't make
any sense whatsoever so fox actually
really has no choice of eventually
supporting whoever is the republican
nominee even if the republican nominee
were eventually like an uh over white
nationalist or something like that
fox would still not support the democrat
they might maybe not not super
aggressively support the republican
candidate maybe they would
but fox has a business model that's
based on we support republicans um and
then number two
uh there is going to be some point at
which it will be clear who the nominee
is going to be it's very unlikely that
the nomination will be contested until
the very end
it's just not usually that way usually
before the media calls it
we kind of in the analysis space
reasonable people we go it's pretty damn
clear who's going to be the nominee
and
that is going to give fox lead time to
in some credible to their audience way
it might not be credible to you and i
but in some way that is sort of credible
to the republican fox news viewer
jump ship to whoever is going to be the
nominee because they can't lose out on
access that's one of the most important
things for a network like fox news you
have to maintain access to the
republican nominee who may eventually be
the president that's their most
important thing that's their business
model we'll have these clips on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show we will take a quick break
and be right back
i've seen several people in my life try
to quit smoking or vaping and quitting
has so many benefits but it does require
a strategy and our sponsor fume is a
one-of-a-kind inhaler that can help you
quit smoking as a replacement for the
hand-to-mouth habit of smoking there is
no smoke there is no vapor and there's
no nicotine fume is just a small inhaler
hand crafted from wood it uses cores
infused with fresh aromatic plant oils
for you to taste and enjoy
instead of a nasty cigarette or a vape
you can use fume while flying which is a
big plus because there's no smoke no
vapor no nicotine fume has flavors like
peppermint and conker with a powerful
minty sensation to simulate the menthol
cigarettes they have other flavors like
cozy chai i love chai myself and lemon
berry bliss for a sweeter experience
fume has helped thousands of people quit
people who have tried everything else
read the reviews we talked to the fume
team they're very proud of the lives
that they've impacted throw out the
cigarettes get rid of the vapes head
over to breathe fume dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman to get 10
percent off your entire order the link
is down below